so I have to tell you Dorinda today the
derobics has proven to me that I'm
completely out of shape
how great was that I want to do it every
day though I do too absolutely so great
and it wasn't that long but I got tired
I was tired too 30 minutes is all you
need that's all you need honestly I just
feel I feel uncomfortable she went off
on me for something so stupid it feels
weird and awkward like why can't she
just come over and apologize
the sandwiches the cucumber sandwiches
amazing they made these at Doritos well
I would do it again tomorrow morning if
you guys want to do an exercise I would
do it I would do it yeah we do it
tomorrow and you guys have to come we'll
plan on going today did you decide
which Hill I just needed a moment you
needed a moment why didn't you come
Vicky they just kind of paused for a
moment I just did it was just a little
bit too much right away on the morning
yeah I agree with you it was a lot
it was very emotional for me because I
don't talk you know I really took so
much to put this all together yeah we
respect that and it was like not that
big of a deal
well it didn't make sense for you to
attack me the way you did oh I didn't
attack okay okay okay and attendant
today so that's why I didn't want to
ruin your aerobics so I just thought I
would let you do your thing well then it
was noticed by all that's right
evidently I screwed up because I didn't
go if I don't want to do aerobics I'm
not gonna do it she made me cry
and then told me not to go we're all
going to be in trouble by the end of the
trip why would I show up and why would I
want to show up it would have been nice
to be a team player and not make a
mountain out of a molehill it sort of
was like weren't we done I just want to
keep making things a thing yeah which is
pointlessed but you weren't there no I
saw you no no no no no no no no this is
a person
come on just stay out of it
you guys you both are a person you need
to I'm talking to Eva I'm enjoying the
cucumber sandwiches can't we just all
get along when she's around you you guys
like you talking Tandem and it's like no
we don't cheers
we listened to Tampa speak now maybe
we've taken the Alice in Wonderland
theme of the Tea Party a little too far
dorinda's turned into the Red Queen
Tweedledee and tweedledown were fighting
with her and now I feel like Alice
flipping down the rabbit hole so why
didn't you come today do I make
I was just checking out because I didn't
like the way you spoke you know you want
to do things separately you know what
there's a lot of conflict going on with
eight women I think I can pause but
there really isn't conflict the only
underlining conflict is you
Vicki's been acting like your daughter
who you absolutely love but you don't
understand why do we have a tube what is
the problem what do you want me to do to
not be so negative I'm not negative I'm
a positive you all said you just asked
the question there's your answer we had
a thing it had nothing to do with you
you should have stayed out of it
it was my yogurt
not mine
I had nothing to do with your yoga or
yours I said it to Tamara and then we
had to say and she jumped in we should
have gotten out there you should have
joined us and you should have shown me
respect as the hostess to do an activity
that I planned for us I'm sorry
[Applause]
the double dutch bus is on the street
again by the way that whole thing just
made me eat five of these I just want to
say you are so hungry I love it thank
God for Jill's hearty appetite this is
the quietest that I've seen her let this
baby eat there's one thing I've learned
after 10 years of being a housewife is I
don't have to get myself involved in
every fight I'm hungry
tonight's going to be a lot of fun yeah
okay what are we to expect for
prohibition oh you're gonna love it as
everyone knows the house was done in the
early 20th century and it was it was
known to be a speakeasy that they would
run liquor through from the Hudson so I
really wanted to do something fun and
different and adventurous and wow them a
bit let's have fun let's drink them
[Applause]
yeah where would I tell you something
you know what I feel like I feel like
Tommy needs a hug I feel like she's
feeling very uncomfortable just my
advice
I'm just not a pandering person and I
don't feel like hugging is what I should
be doing with him
I need a hug
[Music]